[Music]
science essentially math disguised as
dinosaurs and outer space to try and
seem interesting
specifically the story concerns
gene-editing it's a topic you may have
heard about given it's now a plot point
in action movies like rampage what's
happening to my friend are you familiar
with genetic editing changes will be
incredibly unpredictable is he the only
one oh you didn't know about the 30-foot
wall
[Music]
wait a second wait just a second let me
get this straight this is a movie about
aerial military equipment being
harnessed to fight a 30-foot wolf and it
is not called Wolf Blitzer that is a
huge boost opportunity that's movie
malpractice there look gene-editing
isn't only showing up in movie starring
rock the Dwayne Johnson no it's also now
constantly brought up on TV with with
varying degrees of excitement or extreme
alarm a stunning and controversial
breakthrough in science has arrived
gene-editing
this is a milestone that could one day
erase hereditary conditions some fear
the technology could be used to create
designer babies these technology has the
potential to change our DNA and the DNA
of all organisms alive and extinct could
that lead to eugenics could that lead to
new divides in humanity I don't know
that stuff is that's just scary
exactly it seems gene editing is either
going to cure all disease or kill every
last one of us and the truth is anytime
there is a bold new technology people do
tend to go nuts
I'm guessing after the invention of the
refrigerator there were a rash of
headlines like can meat be too cold and
what about the milkman America's
friendly neighborhood we're done so
tonight we thought we'd take some time
to talk about gene editing what it is
what its potential could be and what the
chances are that we're all going to be
killed by a 30-foot wolf and let's start
with the fact that gene noticing
actually isn't new there have been
technologies like these around for years
what is new and what is driving a lot of
recent coverage is something called
CRISPR which stands for crunchy rectums
in sassy pink ray bats
except it doesn't it stands for this but
you won't remember that and you actually
don't need to so let's go back to the
crunchy wrexham thing CRISPR is very
complicated but but one of the key
scientists who unlocked its potential
Jennifer Doudna has a simple way of
explaining how it works I like to use
the analogy of word processing because
it's very analogous to that you think of
the DNA code like the text of a document
this is the scissors that allows you to
cut out text change it the cell takes
over after this after
the DNA is broken and makes a precise
change at the site of the repair right
that is very basically it it's like cut
and paste in Microsoft Word if there's
something that you want to fix on a
strand of DNA with CRISPR you could
theoretically find it cut it out and
paste in a fix
at which point presumably Clippy shows
up and says hi it looks like you're
trying to play God and alter the basic
building blocks of life these sapele
Crispus potential is huge there are
hopes that they might eventually be
applied to more than 10,000 conditions
from sickle cell anemia to cystic
fibrosis to some cases of early onset
Alzheimer's but gene editing is wildly
difficult diseases typically have
multiple genes that contribute to them
and human trials have been extremely
rare although there have been some
promising results just months ago baby
Layla was dying of acute lymphoblastic
leukemia so doctors agreed to try out an
experimental immuno cell therapy which
had never been used outside the lab the
result astounded her parents I took the
gamble and this is her today standing
laughing giggling and I'm the fact with
a miracle that's fantastic
and he's right it is a miracle except
really think about it it's actually not
it's science which I'd argue is actually
better and more convenient than a
miracle because you don't have to spend
the next two thousand years worshiping
the scientist you can just be like
thanks amazing story for the most part
applications of Gina acing have been
confined to experiments on plants and
animals where the results have been
striking if often a little weird
researchers at this lab used CRISPR to
isolate and manipulate the beagles
muscle or myostatin gene making these
the most muscular beagles in the world
okay okay all right so you might think
it's strange that scientists mage act
sexy beagles but did you ever even
consider that the scientists were lady
beetles change your preconceptions about
what a scientist can be hashtag beagle
feminism hashtag science
it's not it's not just we've paid
because scientists are researching ways
to fight human diseases using mice and
while scientists know how painstakingly
slow this kind of research is it is
tempting for the rest of us to start
racing ahead and wildly speculating
about where this is all going could
CRISPR give us unicorns so there are
examples of animals that have single
horns in the middle so like the
rhinoceros has one and its nose but
there are other ancient rhinoceros I
have it in the middle of the head so
anyway I think that you could get a
single horn on a horse by looking at
horns and other species so it's in the
realm of possibility yes okay so so I've
gotta say judging by all the hedging he
just did in that answer even if we do
one day career at a unicorn it's clearly
not going to be this majestic creature
who wants you to follow it into a magic
waterfall it'll be more like this a
monster that would beg please kill me
and this and this madness now in fact in
fact for a good sense of the mismatch
between expectation and current
capabilities just look at a project that
that scientist is working on right now
bringing back the woolly mammoth it has
been hyped in headlines all over the
world but they are nowhere close to
creating a living animal yet and even
computer simulations are underwhelming
in the lab they've edited about 35
functioning woolly mammoth genes into
the Asian elephant genome this is a good
start for making a semi woolly mammoth
yeah that's not a woolly mammoth oh
that's just a wrong elephant
it's not so much Jurassic Park as an
off-brand $3.00 petting zoo cause pet or
whatever but if you watch the news you
may have noticed that you're not just
seeing professional scientists and
that's because the underlying technology
of CRISPR is so cheap and widely
available almost anyone can use it so
gene editing stories almost always
feature a detour to meet bio hackers
like Josiah Zana here in the Bay Area
where visiting a bio hacker in his
garage he's selling CRISPR kids DIY
CRISPR kids for a couple of hundred
dollars you can buy this cutting edge
kit that allows you to use this
technology and you don't need anything
else you don't need a PhD and you could
do experiments with CRISPR like that I
think is really cool okay well sounds
revolutionary but to be fair selling
strangers things covered in unfamiliar
DNA out of your garage already has a
name and it's every single garage sale
in human history I would like to buy
your lamp please and then I'm going to
take it home and wash it and look he's
basically selling chemistry sets in the
extent that they get people excited
about science that's a good thing but
you can see why scientists get
frustrated when biohackers like designer
hog all the media attention especially
because he makes some pretty wild
statements like I want to live in a
world where people get drunk and instead
of giving themselves tattoos they're
like I'm drunk I'm going to crispr
myself which is a terrible idea
honestly you shouldn't even get drunk
and tattoo yourself however cool Robert
Duvall's face covering your midriff
seems at the time I'm just saying I have
some regrets
last October Xena even publicly injected
himself with DNA that had been modified
using CRISPR to try and give himself
bigger muscles which did not work but in
that same video he argued that using
CRISPR should ideally be like
downloading an app you don't have to
know what the app does how to program it
works anything like that and I think
that's the way it should be with genetic
engineering synthetic biology why can't
people use this technology without
necessarily completely knowing how it
works oh I can answer that one for you
because it could be dangerous and
someone could get hurt
also I refuse to take scientific insight
from someone shooting vertical footage
on an iPhone that is unforgivable that
is disqualifying immediately and now
says he regrets that experiment that
kind of behavior is a real worry for
serious scientists not just that a
biohacker will hurt themselves but that
doctors or scientists might rush a human
application before it's ready things go
wrong and the whole field is then set
back yes that is exactly what happened
to the field of gene therapy when a
patient named Jesse Gail singer died
during a poorly designed trial and
that's not the only thing that
scientists worry about because the
benefits and the drawbacks of gene
editing can extend well beyond one
person and to understand why it helps to
be familiar with a key distinction
somatic cells are most of the cells in
the body blood brain skin cells where
the DNA doesn't get passed down to
offspring germline edits involve sperm
eggs or embryos basically changing the
DNA of future generations
exactly somatic cells die with you
germline cells get passed down through
generations so much of what you've seen
so far tonight like baby Layla or Xena's
muscle experiment involved somatic cells
while germline cells are how my
great-grandfather passed this nose down
to me when he this bird great
grandma feathers
she loved bells germline editing could
potentially do incredible things take
malaria nearly half a million people
each year die from it and it's spread by
mosquitoes but gene editing could help
stop that through something called a
gene Drive scientists do this by
inserting an artificial gene into the
DNA of mosquito embryos that will make
an increasing proportion of female
offspring sterile the gene drive is
embedded in the DNA to ensure the
changes are inherited unlike natural
evolution where chance is involved
that's brilliant and it's honestly much
simpler than my idea to fight malaria by
just fitting millions of mosquitoes with
tiny condoms but but the moment you
cross into germline editing the
ramifications can seriously increase
because messing with any ecosystem can
have unintended consequences this has
always been true even before gene
editing and my favorite example of this
comes from Australia we're about a
hundred cane toads were introduced in
the 1930s to control the cane beetle for
the record they didn't do that what they
did do was multiply to hundreds of
millions of cane toads and wreak
absolute havoc Australians hate these
things there was even a documentary made
about them featuring a guy who made it
his life's work to run over as many as
he could well line them up with the
driver's side front wheel but I seem to
be able to get most of the ones I line
up on the right hand side of the road
well I really go out of my way to run
over cane toads basically because I have
a very profound love of the wildlife
that occurs here naturally if it was
possible to remove them and totally
eradicate
in Australia and I was capable of doing
it I would spend a lifetime doing
exactly there
Wow that guy is in for an unpleasant
surprise when he gets to the pearly
gates and finds out that God is an
Australian Kato so you'd like to get
into heaven huh why don't we go ahead
and take a look at the types the point
is ecosystems are very delicate which is
why you need to be extremely careful and
a good example of someone taking that
sort of care with gene-editing can be
seen in a project being considered on
Nantucket Island as a way to fight Lyme
disease you see Lyme disease is passed
from ticks to humans but before that can
happen
it goes from mice to ticks now typically
the way that works is like this and
mouse goes through a tough breakup it
was a relationship the mouse didn't want
to end and leaves it seriously
questioning itself worth the mouse mouse
goes on a series of rebound dates that
only deepen the disillusionment could
anyone love me the mouse wanders
despondent the mouse turns to alcohol to
numb the pain while drunk it comes
across a tinder profile of a tick first
then the mouse is disgusted but then
it's actually intrigued oh god it thinks
am I really going to a tick the
mouse goes on the date thinking it's
just a date we're just talking but the
mouse is lying to itself because as soon
as the tick says maybe we should go
someplace quiet where we can talk BAM
they're banging in the shower I dunno
afterwards the mouse feels strangely
satisfied it feels desirable again as
for the ticket can't wait to brag to its
friends that it just a mouse and
they both forget all about the encounter
until eight months later when the tick
gets a call bad news
you got Lyme disease and that is how
Lyme disease spreads from mice to ticks
sometimes other times the tick bites the
mouse anyway
the point it took to prevent the spread
of lung disease a biologist named Kevin
s belt is considering introducing
genetically edited mice that cannot pass
the disease to ticks and he would do
this with a ton of caution testing it on
an uninhabited island where the
experiment will be contained and it
would only go forward on Nantucket if he
got the buy-in of the local community
and even with all those safeguards he's
aware of the uncertainty although Kevin
s Pelt is confident his engineered mice
will only reduce Lyme disease and not
bring harm to Nantucket's ecosystem he
also knows that absolute certainty and
genetic engineering do not go together I
worry every day that I might be missing
something profound about the
consequences of what we're developing
good I'm glad you do because that is the
kind of caution that you want from
someone in his position he clearly
doesn't want to end up in a limerick
that goes there once was a man from
Nantucket who gathered some mice in the
bucket he altered those mice engineered
with a splice and now all of the
seagulls are dead and look there are
just practical considerations to
germline editing there are huge moral
questions too particularly when it comes
to humans because it raises the
possibility that gene editing could one
day be used not just to fight disease
but for so-called enhancement which
sells you into some pretty dicey
territory even Jennifer Doudna one of
the pioneers of CRISPR sees the danger
of this here she is telling the story of
a dream that she once had that was
pretty on the nose I walked into a room
and a colleague of mine said to me
Jennifer I'd like you to explain the
CRISPR technology to a friend and he
brought me into a room and the person
was sitting with their back to me and as
they turned around I realized was sort
of a horror horror that it was it was
Hitler and it was actually Hitler with a
sort of a pig nose and it almost looked
like a chimeric pig human sort of sort
of creature it's true she had a dream
about pink Hitler
wanting to learn more about CRISPR an
ethical reservations aside she might
also want to examine why her
subconscious thinks that one of her
colleagues is just casually friends with
Hitler
and look clearly the more control people
have over the ability to design their
children the bigger the moral questions
that raises up to and including who
decides what constitutes a genetic
problem that needs to be fixed is
deafness and disease many in the deaf
community would say it is not is
dwarfism a disease and he would say not
the idea that we're all sick that we're
suffering that I suffer from dwarfism no
I live with dwarfism
I've lived with dwarfism for 39 years
I'm proud to be a second-generation
raising a third generation of people
living with dwarfism
I don't suffer I suffer from how society
treats me exactly and there are many
groups who could justifiably worry that
the thing that makes them unique or
different could come to be seen as flaws
to be corrected and eugenics is a word
that rightly terrifies people it's why
it was such a mistake for Eugene Levy to
make that the title of his autobiography
it's a shame it's a shame it was a
lovely book as some great Catherine
O'Hara anecdotes were that that title
really dusted you off now here here is
the thing germline edited designer
CRISPR babies are still a distant
hypothetical no human has been born that
has had its germline edited yet and many
countries have bans or restrictions on
that but one place with very few
restrictions is China which in general
seems eager to push the limits of gene
editing and one of the scientists
working at that jack'd beagle lab seems
to brush off certain ethical issues the
CRISPR allows humans it puts so much
power into our hands it allows us to
shape our world in ways never before
imagined and there are many people in
the US who think well that's no that's
not for us to do that's that's for a
higher power that's for God alright so
the idea that we could
the role of God makes a lot of people
nervous mmm okay well that guy seems a
little bit blase about gene-editing
technology which is kind of surprising
in a country whose president as you may
remember from our show about China is a
honey eating talking bear that's the
resemblance is frightened I can't I
don't know which is which and look and
look my point here in showing you all of
this isn't to frighten you that there is
a lot to be legitimately excited about
here gene-editing has the potential to
alleviate a great deal of human
suffering but reaching that potential
will require careful time-consuming
research the science involved is much
more complicated than we've had time to
get into tonight mainly because we
needed to make space for that long story
about a tick your mouse and I
emphatically stand by that decision but
but well but while that research is
progressing we need to figure out how to
balance the risks and potential rewards
of gene editing which is going to be
tricky because everything that's being
done tends to get mixed together a
meticulous professional scientists with
freewheeling biohackers like this guy
practical applications with wild
theories best-case scenarios like ending
malaria with catastrophic prophecies of
30-foot wolves but but we are going to
need to sort out at some point
where lines should be drawn because
while Gina doesn't could do incredible
things for our health let's at the very
least in future try and avoid a future
where we end up swerving all over the
road try to run over all of the pig
Hitler's that we accidentally created